Have you noticed that when your garbage starts
getting full, there’s a point where the
bag slips off the edges and messes everything
up? Not only does it look terrible and get
in the way, but the bag’s usually so heavy,
you can’t get it to hold back on.
So for this video I’m going to show you
a cool little trick to save you this weekly
frustration, by repurposing a handful of hanging
hooks.
All you need for this household hack, are
two common “command hooks”, which you
can probably find at any grocery, or home
improvement store.
Stick the hooks onto your trash-can so they’re
upside down, and halfway down the sides.
Then double-check you secured them with the
hooks pointing upward, because this won’t
work properly, if they’re the other way
around. Now believe it or not, you’re done.
Simply line your bin, with a fresh, handle-tie
trash bag, and loop the handles over the convenient
hooks you just made, on either side.
As easy as that, your trash bags will hold
neatly in place, making the chore of taking
out the garbage a lot less revolting, because
now, when your garbage starts filling up and
getting heavy, your bag won’t fall into
the can and make a mess like it did before.
Instead, it’ll hold strong, and neatly handle
even more garbage, than it did before.
Now taking out the trash, is so much cleaner
and easier this way as well.
Simply unhook the handles from the sides,
and you’ll instantly have a lot more clean
plastic at the top, when it’s time to tie
it off, and take it out.
Well now you know how to dodge the frustrations
of garbage can gloom, by repurposing common
hanging hooks, into nifty, bag handle holders.
And while you’re down there doing the dirty
work, why not try drilling a few holes into
the bottom of your garbage cans as well?
Little vents like these will prevent any suction
from building up between the bags and the
cans, so your trash sacks will pull out easily,
when you need them to.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com